if by Rudyard Kipling if you can keep
your head when all about you are losing
theirs and blaming it on you if you can
trust yourself when all men doubt you
but make allowance for their doubting
too if you can wait and not be tired by
waiting or being lied about don't deal
in lies or being hated don't give way to
hating and yet don't look too good nor
talk too wise if you can dream and not
make dreams your master if you can think
and not make thoughts your aim if you
can meet with triumph and disaster and
treat those two Impostors just the same
if you can bear to hear the truth you've
spoken twisted by knaves to make a trap
for fools or watch the things you gave
your life to broken and stoop and build
them up with worn-out tools if you can
make one heap of all your winnings and
risk it all on one turn of
pitch-and-toss and lose and start again
at your beginnings and never breathe a
word about your loss if you can force
your heart and nerve and sinew to serve
your turn long after they're gone and so
hold on when there's nothing in you
except the will which says to them hold
on if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue or walk with Kings nor lose
the common touch if neither foes nor
loving friends can hurt you if all men
count with you but none too much if you
can fill the unforgiving minute with
sixty seconds worth of distance run
yours is the earth and everything that's
in it and which is more you'll be a man
my son
you